welcome back y'all i'm kicking it with
kim whitley and an audience full of
single ladies give it up y'all
it is part two of our single ladies
celebration and
who knows how many parts of this
celebration we will have it's up to us
i own the show we're gonna do whatever
we want um only time in the bottoms of
our
our bottomless beverages will tell not
bottomless justin just the one we'll do
um during our very first celebration
we had many women in our audience share
their stories and ask questions
they were enlightening empowering and
many were just
hilariously funny um so we want to hear
some more because it was fun
so let's start with madison what's your
single life like madison
hi kelly and kim um it's going well
so i've enjoyed being single i've
enjoyed having this time to really just
get to know myself and learn more about
myself on a deeper level
however not everyone views being single
as a positive thing and they feel sorry
for me and they're constantly trying to
set me up on date
so one of those people being my grandma
she could just not
accept me being single so she set me up
on three blind dates before she passed
away one of them was with a guy
um that she met at a coffee shop
that she went too often um he was in a
band and she thought
he was like the greatest thing that
walked this planet don't do it
and so i finally gave in and i was like
okay so i went on one date with him
only to discover upon seeing him that he
was
my school's drug dealer what
yeah i didn't i didn't see that one
coming here's my question
ma'am how did you know he was the drug
dealer you took it you took it
yeah i was gonna get there actually so
everyone knew like everyone knew his
name
disclaimer i did not use his services i
promise
i'm not judging just wondering
but immediately i recognized him just
because like everyone kind of knew who
he was
um and so let's just say that date did
not go as planned
um i loved my grandma dearly but you
know she sure knew how to pick them
aren't glenn dates the best so my
question to you
is what's the worst playing date
experience that you've ever had
oh wow well first of all uh
applause to your grandma you know a
grandma
three times dead uh her grandma she was
really looking out for
to be in the coffee shop to go up to a
stranger and say
uh look uh my uh desperate granddaughter
uh i mean why the worst what in the
world i hear grandma what i love her
grandma what are she saying to these
people
um for me i have had
a lot of bad ones but i've enjoyed every
experience but
my experience was kind of like hers my
girlfriend was telling me about this guy
and how nice he was but she never said
his name
she was just like one day you know
you're going to meet you got to meet him
i got to hook you guys
up and it was the same thing we were at
a restaurant she was like
come come come on come on go he's here
he's here come on come on we're
we're having some to eat and i walk in
and it's my cousin no
it is like but it's a distant cousin
she didn't know you know it's like your
third cousin i know it was horrible i
walked in he sees me i see him
we got the same dimples everything else
oh my god
oh it was horrible she or
funny it was we laughed oh we were dying
oh my god she felt so bad because she
was like
i should have said the name i should
have told you i said i
i asked you what was he made oh my god
and so that was probably my
uh how horrible i've never been on a
blind date so after i kissed him no go
ahead i'm just playing
he is my cousin kissing
no i've never been on a blind date i
don't know that i would do a blind date
not yet yeah you would i don't know i
called you and said
so no i mean no he's everything i've
checked him out i've vetted him
just just come on and just meet him okay
no but if he's everything why are you
passing them on to me
because you have to understand i already
got seven of them lined up over here
i'm giving you number eight i don't i
don't think i'd do a blind
i think i really no i don't think i i'm
not already nervous enough if i know the
dude
not even just for the fun no i don't
think that would be fun
i think that would be terrifying really
really
i need you to live i'm sweating right
now just thinking about it
it's so much fun i'm also in spanx and
drinking okay yeah
yeah you would not do a blind date i
don't think so
but whatever you know why because it's
not fair at this point it's not fair if
i weren't famous
i would do a blind date but that's not
fair it's not blind for them
no they don't what if they don't test
say well they walk in the freaking
restaurant and see my face or hear my
voice they're going
and then i know nothing about them no
what if your girlfriend says
here he is on paper this is everything
about okay okay okay if it's not like
completely blind
right some kind of like you got it what
if she shows there's a catalog i'm like
picking it right that was gonna say
where's the camera and she shows you a
picture
and said i didn't tell him who you were
but i told him you're very nice and
okay i might do something like that okay
not now but like
way longer right now yeah well you say
way long like 20 years because i'm
dating myself and i'm enjoying it hey
okay wait a minute y'all that's true
that's true that was a good i like
dating myself thank you so much madison
yeah i date myself too and i ghosted
myself too i got it
okay okay i went too far i went too hard
i have to be the party kim because no
one's
actually here i'm a practicer we are
well into part d of our single ladies
celebration and we're chatting it up
with our fellow single ladies in the
audience and flat out enjoying our best
selves on our own
so let's keep the train moving with
talisha hi talisha
hi hi kelly
hi kim all right let me tell you so i've
been
celebrating being happily single for a
little minute you know
i don't want just any relationship i
want the relationship
so i'm not rushing it i'm sitting back
chilling you know minding my business
and i think guys just kind of take it
the wrong way
like i've been told a couple times by
different um single men
they don't approach me because i look
married already
right um so i asked them what they meant
and they said because i don't look
single
and desperate well who wants on the
other hand
what in the world on the other end of
that coin though i'm
constantly approached by married men to
have affairs
because i'm married already you know so
i guess now i too
have something to lose what what's the
what's the worst compliment you've
gotten from a guy oh
oh that i'm still at how you look
married what you got on
you got on some memes some slippers and
a captain what are you watching around
how are you looking you've got rollers
in your head and you're over it what's
happening
you look happy i don't know what's that
i don't know what that means
yeah like you don't look desperate i'm
like do you want me to look desperate
that says more about you dude than me
um that's really weird take that
the worst thing a guy's ever said you
know what this is
this person might know who i'm talking
about but here's the thing
i didn't i wasn't really feeling it like
i was into somebody else and
and i didn't want to tell anyone because
i'm pretty shy and anyway
so this other person was trying to set
me up with someone that they knew
and i was like oh god i don't want to
look like i'm interested in this person
so
anyway finally this girlfriend like wore
me down
to give she was like can i please just
give your number to him i promise you
he's so cool this is why i don't do that
i like it i like it anyway she was like
i promised she was great blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah
then finally i'm like oh just give my
number just if it makes you feel awkward
and i'll just
i'll shut it down like nicely like
because i was into someone so
and i'm very focused and so anyway i
got a first text from him it was either
the very first text
or the second text and if it wasn't the
first text and the first text was high
kelly
and the second text was you have a nice
ass
and i was like was he black i literally
no no that was his second that was his
introduction to me
you have a nice ass and i i literally
just texted back
charming and i changed my number
this is a woman with an ass let me
explain to y'all
what no that's because you got an ass
women with little asses like me
if i got one text and man said you got a
nice ass i mean like for real
no no that's his first like
entrance like that's like something you
said you've been dating a minute and i'm
maybe i'm like oh i have a little fat in
this like that's something you saw in
there like no i have a nice ass
not like the first time you talk to me
like i don't have time for that all
right you might be
yeah right i wish i just want one of the
cameramen the sound people the band
members hey bad
i'm taking i'll take it
say it again
[Laughter]
you made him sing with that with that
what's the worst thing that any any guy
like ever lie any longer
okay um he said
oh my god you have your father's lips
wait wait
so what are you going to want to kiss
them at some point because now i feel
like
i'm uncomfortable oh you look like your
brother without hair okay
everybody's gone it's over yes i i've
had
men say crazy things i've had men shower
me with money after a
comedy show he just gave me all this
money like i could be bought
after i picked up all the money
i was like no i'm not interested but
thank you i was like
ridiculous this will scare you
oh my gosh well thank you so much to
lisa and i think you look fabulous
any way you want to look and you don't
you know what i see that as you're
picking the weeds
you know you haven't found the flowers
so that's all right i've got kim whitley
on one hand and a mojito in the other
and an audience of awesome single ladies
life is good everybody
it is part two of our single ladies
celebration hanging out and swapping
stories
next up we've got juanita let's tell
your story juanita
hi kelly hi kim um i am celebrating
being single currently
uh my last relationship left my
self-esteem pretty low
i've been building it up for the last
four years of being single
um i like my butt i like my legs and i
love my smile you know
so something i've been looking into is a
boudoir photo shoot
for myself i even have a little outfit
picked out it's pink and black and
gonna make me feel so confident what's
something you've done for your
sexy single self wait wait wait wait
we're going back to you
yeah she she said she got a little pink
outfit she about to get
naked on the couch be like this wait
wait
wait what's this is it a good what
that's the bedroom booth wise french or
something
french span or something wait what is
that wait so you
what what do you do there's sexy photo
shoot for yourself
a sexy photo shoot in the boudoir here's
the thing when you
are in the public eye you never allow a
camera
near your naked behind
you might cover it up a little bit i'd
like to
i'd like to do that scene in uh nine and
a half weeks
uh with kim basinger remember the food
on their body i want to take a picture
and the food was
like i'd like to put some um some ribs
like a little that just seems like a
waste of good food no i didn't say it
was gonna be wasted now
we're gonna put some ribs or a rack of
lamb
[Laughter]
can you imagine to take a picture with a
rib in my mouth and
in the booth no
i just i think that that makes you feel
really good and i love that you said you
love your butt and your smile
and and all the things about you know
i'm sorry that you're in a relationship
where somebody
um you know kind of took that from you
for a minute um but here's the
thing like never let them have that
power in the first place like
because i don't know there's so you know
something everybody likes something
different so it's like okay cool you're
not into it somebody else might be
you know so um i don't know i say never
put your eggs in their basket ever keep
them in your basket that's right
yeah and accidentally send the pictures
out oh
only if they look good in their body
right and the lighting is going to be i
don't know how you got that picture
that's crazy i'm like yeah
i do that all the time oops that's crazy
yeah
all i'm saying if people say they got
naked picture me they lying because i
would never do that
ain't no cameras around no and you know
people know those cameras there because
no one looks like that in those things
you know they're all like perfectly lit
and they're just like you know
nobody looks like that when you're
making everybody looks weird yeah yeah
thank you so much juanita um all right
you guys have been bringing it with the
stories
uh but before we go to break i want to
thank you all for sharing
by serving up a little pampering because
i think it's nice to do that for
everybody
soothe brings licensed and trained
wellness professionals directly to your
home or office
with massage hair or beauty services to
choose from soothe
brings everything you need to treat
yourself to a day of self care
everyone in the house seats is getting a
200 gift card for supe
yup i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever